I had a miscarriage which I now think is
because of the fibroids which were
growing et was first to talk to Bethenny
Frankel as she revealed her secret
health problems The Real Housewives of
New York star was diagnosed with
multiple fibroids on her uterus and had
to have them surgically removed I spoke
to her at her home in New York how did
you get through that the miscarriage
based on things that were going on in my
personal life and my marriage I think
that later I sort of just marketed to
myself as that was not meant to be
because it would have made things even
more difficult than they already were I
definitely felt like I went through that
alone Bethany's doctor gave her three
options and one was a hysterectomy but
she decided to go another route so does
that mean more kids I don't know you
know so many strange surprising things
have happened to me that I feel like you
just have to let nature run its course
well on last week's episode we saw you
mention your personal life a little bit
he's like I'm in love with you and I
want to spend I'd marry you tomorrow how
are things going with that gentleman who
you alluded to I'm really really happy
right now
when I was uh in the very very the most
negative part of my divorce I would say
it's gnarly its girl
and it really it can be it's been the
worst experience of my life
so I'm ready to let the good times roll
now the surgery's past me hopefully soon
my marriage will be past me and life is
good would you get married again I said
I'd never get legally married again okay
I don't like the idea of a piece of
paper being involved in a marriage I
don't like the idea of a prenup
ironically because no
one more than I did I dub always
believes in love I am a hopeless
romantic and I've said I said in my book
with I suck at relationships that I you
people used to think that I sucked at
business and I did and I eventually
figured out having that such a business
so I think that one of these days I will
definitely be able to say that I don't
separately
you